you can grow mint in the ground but this  is where we have our disclaimer ferment  mint is a very aggressively growing  plant that means that where you plant  mint it will expand and it will pop up  all over your garden so my tip for you  in growing men is to either grow it in a  pot  or grow it in a raised bed  if you don't want to dedicate a whole  raised bed to mint  you can actually bury a pot  in the soil  and that will help keep mint in this  area  take your pot and your pot can be as big  as you want if you want a bigger section  of mint if it's at soil level those  runners would expand right across the  soil so you want to leave it high up  keeping your mint in check if you don't  want it to take over